six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number
let's go next well let's just check in
with Dante from Florida who I want to
get it right Dante because every time
you correct me you are a Bernie guy but
you like tulsi is that correct yes I'm a
Bernie Sanders supporter and I will
defend both together when she's correct
got it okay good what's going on um so
what had were so there are a lot of from
the left-wing intellectuals like dr.
Cornel West normally they make the point
that you can't really have a left-wing
movement without a real criticism of US
foreign policy
so my question is for all people who
consider themselves progressives and
leftist and non interventionist
shouldn't Elizabeth Warren's foreign
policy be a disqualifying factor for
what which which position of her
specifically though do you mean
I mean her a lot of her positions on
foreign policy are just bad she's not
really she hasn't really had well on the
israel-palestine conflict back in that
thing was like 2014-2015 some like that
when then Yahoo was doing the the
massacre in Gaza and the West Bank she
was literally using uh is um idea of
talking points about human shields and
they have to defend themselves and all
that um on other issues like Yemen she
hadn't really been out front and it's
important that and voting on on the
military budget but it's important that
especially in the time that we're now
we're in a the illegal wars the illegal
war in Iraq Yemen Syria it's important
that we have somebody who's out front on
these issues of foreign policy and
wasn't just one is definitely not gonna
do that she she usually goes along with
whatever the establishment wisdom is in
the national security apparatus and she
lives the generals
if you're gonna do that in the White
House it's just gonna be a continuation
of the disaster if US foreign policy so
let's see if we can disaggregate some of
those things I mean so the her vote on
military spending is the one thing that
you've mentioned that is the most
concerning to me and I'm absolutely on
board as far as that goes you know her
line about Israel has to be allowed to
defend itself Bernie Sanders literally
used that same line during his 2016
campaign and it angered a lot of people
on the left but that is not that that
line you know Bernie used that line as
well and that is not really a concern to
me what's more of a concern to me is
what is going to be the relationship
between the American president and the
sometimes right-wing governments of
Israel in terms of looking other the
other way when it comes to things like
settlements for example or what have you
so I don't think that that line from
Elizabeth Warren from five years ago is
is particularly problematic now as you
mentioned I think that Elizabeth Warren
will just listen to the generals I
believe that basically everybody who has
a shot at this thing on the Democratic
side is going to listen to the generals
and I don't think that that's a bad
thing in a sense I mentioned last week a
lot of people write in to me Dante and
they say David aren't you worried that
Bernie will weaken our military aren't
you worried that Warren will weaken our
military that they won't do anything if
we're attacked I think that Biden Warren
and Bernie who are the three people at
this point who have a shot all recognize
unlike Donald Trump that they are not
the experts about when and how to use
the military and they are going to
listen to their generals and the
Pentagon I don't think that that's
different with the three of them what is
different is from it from a geopolitical
perspective their outlook on some of
these conflicts and issues but I think
when it comes down to the issues of
national security I think they're all
gonna listen to the generals yeah I'll
extend logistic we like okay if we need
more troops like Bernie Sanders he says
he wants to end the war so he wants to
get our troops out of Iraq Afghanistan
Syria and all these are the conflicts so
he's not he's not going to be deferring
to the general
hello all right we lost Dante okay it's
weird I thought it sounded like there
was a kid screaming or a cat screeching
and then we suddenly lost him which was
very very strange let's go to a quick
break and then we'll come back and do
more calls right after this unclear what
it is that happened with the phone
system there but we will figure it out
and then be right back